Question 1 - Matt asks, do you think Zaheer
was working with Kuvira.
To destablize the government so Kuvira could
take over?
Was she a member of the Red Lotus?
Question 2 - Sventu Sventu asks, will the
White Lotus deal with The Red Lotus?
Question 3 - Death God Riku asks, Do you think
Toph is a White Lotus Member?
Question 4 - Joe Swamson asks, Do you think
it’s bad I’m more in favor of Kuvira than
the Earth Prince?
Question 5 - Aaneik Maiti asks, Do you think
Kuvira will go after the Fire Nation?
Question 6 - Cyrus Wadia asks, Do you think
Korra will find Toph on her own?
Question 7 - Full Time Slacker asks, do you
think Kuvira is Evil or just an opportunist?
Question 8 - Korra Olsson asks, why is Korra
fighting in earth bending games instead
of
another element?
Question 9 - Camile asks who do you think
Korra will back this season, Kuvira or Republic
City?
Everyone vs Kuvira
Question 10 - Corey asks, Why does
Mako have to work for the Earth Prince?
Why doesn’t he quit if he doesn’t like
it?
Winner -
Catherine McGuire